this is the latest we have from inside
the Soyuz capsule a progestin or tim
peake along with tim kopra from the US
and yuri malenchenko from russia the
three astronauts that are due to blast
off from kazakhstan just after eleven
o'clock this morning up to the
International Space Station they're
carrying out their pre-flight checks at
the moment we don't think this is live
we don't think it is life I'm actually
seen some pictures which will play a rat
will play with internal a very quickly
showing some of these rituals that go
back to nineteen sixty one the first
successful flight by yuri gagarin into
low-earth orbit for instance they watch
the same film on the eve of blast off
they do a number of other things at all
of which are repeatable necessarily they
also sign their accommodation doors
there it is and when you think that 220
astronauts and cosmonauts have been on
board the International Space Station
since 2000 that's quite a lot of signage
not all of them of course have blasted
off from Kazakhstan many of them from
the United States as well but since the
shuttle stop flying to the ISS through
the workhorse has become the Soyuz craft
so everything that's going to the ISS is
going in a sense it is bearing
astronauts it's coming from Kazakhstan
and as yesterday we saw the spacecraft
being blessed by an orthodox priests so
today the astronauts and cosmonauts as
wellness fair crew lined up behind them
I miss the last chance that they'll have
had to see their families as well we
know that Tim Peaks families out there
with him it's like Rebecca four-year-old
Oliver and Thomas's six out there as
well this fonts are allowed but he's had
to be separated from one in the last
couple of days just so he doesn't take
infection with them up to the
International Space stage any do fist
pump fist pumps you just did that we did
but they're meant to be quarantined on
those be unless they take any disease
into space where the effects were all
serious and they would be on earth well
there's a limit to how much disease you
can get from her he continues to be all
actually look remarkably relaxed I
suppose the amount of testing in terms
of the process that's led them to this
position it was actually originally on
the internet that Tim pika was flying
army helicopters some lovely Singh's say
goodbye the children of sweet so all the
testing that's been done they've been
evaluated to within an inch of their
lives you can be sure to make sure
they've got the right stuff and he is of
course is his first flied it's the first
briton to go up there and international
space station but but tim kopra and yuri
malenchenko that he's traveling with are
both very experienced it's tim kopra
second flight yuri malenchenko is the
mission commander the russian onboard
very experienced he's done five flights
so far 641 days in space so you perhaps
no surprise that the he is pretty
relaxed he's no end of it yeah and all
this suiting up processes that put into
their spacesuits takes a long time a lot
of the technology is that it's pretty
whiskery Amanda Sawyer's itself first
flew in the late 1960s so it's
incredibly dated and if you look at some
of the apparatus on the launch pad
itself it looks if not rusty and tired
then it certainly looks dated but the
Russians take the view that if it ain't
broke don't fix it it's proved
remarkably successful you could argue
more successful than more modern space
vehicles the obvious example tragically
being the space shuttle which is no
longer flying of course but there have
been through this many many times and
simulations
and the the pressure trousers they wear
as well the pressure suit of course
their bodies will be gained through
g-forces it's all about keeping the
blood up in there in the head to stop
and blacking out on takeoff which
ordinary jet fighter pilots wear as well
as of course bring a forward test pilot
Tim people know all about that this is a
very long process getting into their
suits it takes a couple of hours i do
believe to get actually suited up before
they then go into the capsule and then
prepared all the pre-flight preparations
that they have to carry out before the
launch around an hour and 30 minutes
away from that now and one thing we
haven't mentioned this morning but its
lead we've been trying to get hold of
david willetts all two-brains david
willetts former science minister because
in a sense he's the reason why you
looking at these pictures because the
British government hitherto took the
view that it was gonna back unmanned
space exploration but a science Minister
David Willetts said no it is of
inspiring the next generation we're
going to support new European Space
manned program and that's the reason why
a little belatedly you might argue
obviously Helen Charmin fluid 25 years
ago first British astronaut but that was
a privately funded mission to the MIR
space station this is officially
sanctioned government funded and he will
be timp equally we hope successfully
arrives on the International Space
Station the first British astronaut to
reach the I SS first time we've seen
that that union jack flag on the arm of
a an astronaut and the mission is amiss
the mission badge the mission badged
obviously each mission has its own badge
is real interesting as well not really
you can pick it out but it's he's got an
apple on the badge it's the Principia
mission and tim peaks the reason for
that he wanted it to be in honor of
Isaac Newton yeah named after Newton's
work in 1687 that laid out the laws of
motion and gravity there was a
competition to design this particular
badge won by a little boys from the UK
and he decided with an apple it's also
got the colors of the union flag around
the outside of this badge as well as a
replica of the rocket that
and there was just behind in a picture
of the International Space Station we
keep trying to give you a sense of what
it's like on the ISS the scale involved
outside of a football pitch which
doesn't quite capture it but you get a
broad sense what we're talking about 100
billion pounds it took to assemble from
1998 onwards it's been 15 years in orbit
at its current orbit finally completed
of course they were just bolting bits on
laboratories living capsules or rest of
it finally completed fully as you see it
behind them in that picture in 2008 and
orbits some 240 miles above the earth
it's in a constant state effectively of
freefall at 17 and a half thousand miles
such as the Sun sets and Rises no fewer
than 16 times in any given day and this
one of the reason that the carrying out
experiments up there is so fascinating
as well as a little weightlessness and
all those things that come with it
they're looking at the effect of on your
body clock of sun's rising in session 16
times a day what effect that has on you
that there's part of the experiments
three crew are already up there of
course they said goodbye to some of
their colleagues just a couple of days
ago there'll be interested obviously to
have two new workmates and new people to
spend time with in a really close close
proximity it takes a certain kind of
person you can successfully do something
like that to stay in this very very
small space for up to six months at a
time with people you know you're not
particular friend of it well II but but
you certainly know jolly well yeah six
months on email this morning from
somebody saying how do they lose to hold
it all together again on with people
perhaps that they they discreet decision
with the students has been made on their
behalf they've got small living quarters
no bigger than a phone booths that they
can zip up and privacy is obviously a
big part of what they do this looks like
one of the two books the two boys Thomas
did Oliver this was his last chance a
chat with them through through the glass
just before we set off
i'm guessing the bad as a Tim copperas
family from the US as well as some Tim
Peaks wife Rebecca and children his mum
and dad are out there as well Nigel and
Angela enormously proud of what their
sons achieved they always knew you
wanted to be a pilot I never thought
we'd see the day there are two right at
the French ever see the donut even
remade into space his father said he
worries more about tim peake traveling
down the m27 in hampshire videos are not
flying into space and it's worth bearing
in mind is look at this that Tim beak
Tim Peake a scene is training and now
this mission as an opportunity to
proselytize really on behalf of manned
space flight he's keen to talk about
things like how the space station
ultimately become a staging post
tensioning the colonization of both the
Moon and ultimately Mars as well and
coupled that with the fact you've got
people like Elon Musk internet
billionaire who are pumping lots of
private-sector cash now into space
exploration as well so what you're
looking at here which is
government-funded space exploration is
only part of the story of what's
happening in terms of man flies into
near-earth orbit and Beyond and is roll
out there is it's part maintenance it's
part making sure that the ISS stays
working stays operational and part
scientific 265 experiments to be carried
out by tim peake over the next six
months going to be looking at growing
blood vessels how that works in space
what's the effect of weightlessness on
that how protein crystals are formed and
also about melting alois about working
out the structure of metal and if that
could be used back on earth to make
metal lighter easy to use more for
it's always that question that people
ask isn't it why we're spending all this
money on space exploration one of the
answers to that question well maybe flak
in a big way the well ensign one of the
answers that question of course is that
often times there are unforeseen
positive byproducts some of the best
examples in tech log is it wasn't teflon
news for the original Apollo moon shots
now you will have it our frying pans
he's going to be doing a lot of keeping
fit up there as well he's a really keen
athlete and one of the things you're
gonna be doing what is right in here
he's going to run the London Marathon up
there at the same time and he's also
offering a a chance for children at
schools to take part it's a project
called space to earth challenge this is
to get youngsters to exercise alongside
and the idea is that that youngsters try
to cover 250 miles which is the distance
from space to earth over the six months
he's up there well there you go in just
over an hour major tim peake will become
the first British astronaut Daria's life
two greatest pitchers from his side the
Soyuz capsule they get two hours in
there before the launch which is just
over an hour away from there on the
Kazakhstan step in Baikonur we're going
to your life villains coming
you